the Joe Rogan experience what was your
first appointment like so my first one
was with the team at Hawaii where we
were doing submersible work so I drove
like a 22 foot mini sub for five years
really oh yeah and we were doing some
like waterborne activities and how deep
is it go that's classified
oh really but yeah oh I can go really
deep yeah but it's it's a wet submarine
so we run we run scuba it's all like
you're you're in the water not just
underwater oh really
yeah so you're wearing scuba gear while
you're piloting the yelling so the water
gets in there yep whoa the cut you can
probably pull up a picture of it brother
that's a mindfuck on top of a mine far
SDV just being in a scuba is crazy but
being a scuba gear inside of a [ __ ]
submarine with the door shut oh Christ
so how much hair you got in there enough
that's not a boat oh so it's like a
convertible it no no no so behind those
dudes yeah those doors there's lighters
so you shut them so cuz it can drive
relatively fast we're like if you had
them open like [ __ ] it'd be like oh that
looks like something from a [ __ ]
James Bond movie this doesn't it is like
something phone [ __ ] James Bond movie
like reason we train in the daytime it
is bananas
it is wild to drive that thing I can
only imagine cuz you're landing on the
back of a submarine
it's 22 feet long
ish I I mean that's what I recall
fuckin'-a that we can cool it looks fake
it's like if I saw that in the movie I
but they don't have one of those yeah
that's [ __ ] it does doesn't it it's
like a human torpedo yeah that's what it
looks like it looks like a [ __ ]
missile it is [ __ ] it's pretty cool
Wow so does wild there's a ton of those
things that other countries have like
they've been using submersibles since
the first world war no you know so did
they first invent submarines okay no I
think I think the Revolutionary War
there was a guy that like paddles ass
around in a in like a
seen the car it's like an old Cheryl
yeah it's like crazy-looking wow I'm
just gonna go imagine that first
gangster to [ __ ] climb into a metal
dick and slide in the oceans later got
this even the guys that went the deepest
did it like in the 30s or 40s and no
one's been able to do that again
why didn't smack weird yeah really and
they had a window there's like four
inches across inside I think you sprags
when they got to the bottom oh [ __ ] just
calculations at time you actually get
down there and then you think like back
to your question how much hair do we got
oh my god I guess we have enough oh my
god yeah that to me freaks me out about
more than anything in the water as a
submarine the idea of being in one of
them tubes and sliding around and not
being able to see using sonar and you
think like what's in the water there's
some big-ass animals in the water bigger
sound
big-ass animals guys all they do is bump
you incredible stress fracture I've seen
whales and sharks and dolphins and all
sorts of crazy [ __ ] down there go what
kind of crazy [ __ ]
man we were on the bottom once and we
saw this like scorpion crab looking
thing like walking around on the ground
it was like this tall like work so
you're making the like like a Great Dane
yeah real good like a crab a crab like
Great Dane underwater underwater is
ridicu I don't know what it was but it
was terrifying is it that's is that an
undocumented animal I'm sure it's
documented there's a bunch of those
weird like spider crab looking things
walk around [ __ ] well they don't know
what everything is in the Osher
constantly pulling up new [ __ ] like look
at this thing it's like the size of a
car like well what's really weird is
those really really old ones at the
bottom that people had they only come up
when they get like a tsunami washes I'm
sure have you ever seen those websites
dedicated like the stuff that was in the
Thailand tsunami I go way down the
rabbit hole on some of that crap those
things don't even look real and they've
pulled like I think they recently got a
whale that had a spear tip in it from
like 200 years ago or a hundred and
fifty years ago like so it's a curl
living well yeah woah yeah so a hundred
and fifty years ago during the Moby Dick
day someone harpooned it yeah and it
lived I'm I think that I have heard this
recently yeah Wow these animals are
crazy I mean those Greenland sharks
lived to be like 300 or something no
[ __ ]
yeah that's what they that what they
think that well that's one of the
theories about the Loch Ness monster
that it might be some sort of a
landlocked Greenland shark yeah yeah or
just people full [ __ ] I'm going with
number two I'm going with number two
like how you feel about Sasquatch that's
how I feel about that [ __ ] if there's
enough scary [ __ ] out there yeah we
don't need to make up a Loch Ness
monster it doesn't make any sense
no I just think that people see things
in the water and then they exaggerate
the size of them and the next thing you
know they're telling story there's
probably some [ __ ] in there like some
eels
I'm sure or maybe a sturgeon or
something like that virgin or huge the
size of this deaths are so big and if
you saw one from a distance at night you
would assume that that was a monster or
an alligator gar alligator gar yeah oh
here it is
scroll down please yes I can see the
title but they all survives harpoon
attack a hundred and thirty years ago to
become the world's oldest mammal look at
that harpoon go ahead well I'm glad I
wasn't full [ __ ] out embedded in his
neck Wow is that not insane it was
caught off Alaska so how'd they catch it
this is biologists claim the fine helps
prove the bowhead is the oldest living
mammal on earth says a 13 centimeter
arrow shaped fragment dates back to
around 1880 Wow meaning the 50 ton whale
had been coasting around with his
freezing our Arctic waters since the
Victorian times that's nuts man wild and
since they never took calves they
estimated the bowhead was several years
old when it was first shot and about 130
when it died last month also it died
god damn and it probably died because
they caught it I mean it can't be good
for it yeah it's just weird how many
different things they used to do with
the whales these two tournament the
lamps here they still lamp oil and shut
they used to eat them yeah they still do
[Applause]